[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to today's
webinar responding to sars kobe 2
variants such as omicron detection and
surveillance
my name is jeffrey casell i'm with
thermo fisher scientific and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational webinar is presented
by lab roots and it's brought to you by
thermo fisher scientific
to learn more please visit
thermofisher.com
backslash
covid19 we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
may have during the presentation
to do so simply type them in the ask a
question box that you see to the right
and then click submit
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the talk
you may also submit any technical issues
here if you have any trouble um seeing
or hearing the webinar
in addition to asking questions we
encourage you to check out our latest
resources including a new infographic on
the s gene target failure that you can
see on the left hand side of your screen
and finally we have a survey question at
the bottom center if you'd like to learn
more information about the taqman
mutation panels which you'll hear about
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
icon on the far left of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers for
today's webinar
vanessa lacey is a scientist at therma
fisher scientific with a phd in
biomedical sciences from the university
of california at san diego
and a bachelor's in cellular and
molecular biology from cornell
university
vanessa has extensive experience in the
development of ivds and field service
support
auditing of quality management systems
medical devices and ivds for notified
bodies
and research experience in molecular
biology protein engineering and chemical
biology
in her current role vanessa acts as a
liaison between research and development
and marketing and business development
to support scientists using molecular
diagnostic assays and instruments
and also we have elena fenenstra
she has executive diagnostic and
research experience in genetics
cytogenetics and genomics and has a phd
in experimental oncology from the
medical university of vienna
she is the author of over 25
publications and a recipient of several
awards from professional organizations
including the american society of
hematology and the unesco fellowship for
women in science
in her current role elena is responsible
for driving medical and scientific
affairs activities in europe the middle
east and africa to help democratize
molecular testing globally
vanessa is going to kick us off today so
vanessa you may now begin your
presentation thank you
in the first half of the talk i'll
discuss how the pandemic and strategies
to detect cove 19 have evolved diving
deeper into the rapid response from
thermo fissure specifically i'll show
you how the assay design of our
attackpath rttcr tests were built with
variance in mind and why our test can
still accurately detect stars covered
two when there's so much variability in
the spike protein region
i'll then show you how the tax path
assays can be scaled up for automated
high throughput testing using the
amplitude solution wrapping up my
section with an example from the
university of colorado and how they were
able to not only meet record high volume
testing demands using amplitude but also
monitored the spread of the alpha
variant by tracking the s gene target
failure pattern
i'll then pass it over to dr feinster to
talk to you more about mutations and
variants specifically omricon and how
the taqman mutation panel and sequencing
solutions can be and are being used for
surveillance
so with that i'll show you how the
evolution of the pandemic has gone with
along with testing so far so here's a
global snapshot of the coven 19 pandemic
as of
february 28th the graph on the right
depicts the confirmed number of cases
recorded by each who region per week
with the majority of reported cases in
green and yellow coming from europe and
the americas
as of the day of this recording there's
been over 430 million cases and
heartbreakingly
over 6 million people have died despite
all the hard work sweat and tears from
the front line workers scientists and
epidemiologists all over the world cover
19 has not gone away
although as we continue to understand it
adapt to it and better educate ourselves
in the public i hope that we will reach
endemic status and no longer have to
suffer through these waves of
hospitalization and death
what we now understand from sequencing
and genotyping data is that the first
clear peak you can see here in the graph
in the march to june 2021 time point
coincides with the emergence of the
alpha variant that first emerged from
the uk
that was quickly followed by delta
which was responsible for that second
deadly wave that overtook india and
quickly spread through the rest of the
world in the may through december time
frame
we were then quickly overtaken by
omricon coming out of south africa in
late 2021 and that resulted in the third
and largest wave that only now is on the
downslope
incidence of omricon in many countries
has now far exceeded the incidents ever
reported earlier in the pandemic
so now i'll ask you to quickly take a
mental snapshot of the shape of this
graph before i show you a little bit
more about the situation in the u.s and
explain why accurate testing data is so
important
if you look at the red line you can see
that the situation in the u.s mirrors
what's happening globally
i want to note that the blue histogram
of daily cases and the seven day rolling
average in red represent the confirmed
number of cases reported to the cdc
so what does it mean to be confirmed
well of course that depends on testing
the world health organization defines a
confirmed case as a person with
laboratory confirmation of cova-19
infection
in the published case definitions the
who differentiates between pcr and
antigen tests if you have a positive pcr
test that's considered a confirmed case
irrespective of clinical signs and
symptoms whereas those with a positive
antigen test are not considered a
confirmed case unless other criteria are
also met
nucleic acid amplification tests naat
also known as polymerase chain reaction
tests or pcr
are considered the gold standard
they were considered the gold standard
of testing very early on due to the high
sensitivity accuracy and ability to
accommodate widespread testing
testing really is our window to
understanding this virus not only to
guide patient care but also for how to
understand how the pandemic is spreading
so now let's take a look at the orange
line
which is the seven-day moving average of
percent positivity by pcr or the portion
of laboratory performed tests that had a
positive result
so why is it important to track percent
positivity according to
ourworldanddata.org in a paper published
by the same group in nature scientific
data there's two reasons
one percent positives can track how
adequately countries are testing by
indicating the level of testing relative
to the size of the outbreak
countries with more widespread outbreaks
need to do more testing
and second percent positives in
conjunction with data on confirmed cases
helps us to understand the spread of the
virus if testing was limited many cases
would be missed in regions with a high
percent positive rate the number of
confirmed cases is likely to represent
only a small fraction of the true number
of infections
and where the positive rate is rising
this can suggest that the virus is
actually spreading a lot faster than the
growth seen in the confirmed cases in
blue
so despite the record-breaking number of
daily cases reported to the cdc in the
most recent search this winter the high
percent positive rate indicates that the
number of confirmed cases may be vastly
underestimated even more than usual
next slide please
so now that we have a better
understanding of why testing is so
important for tracking the spread of the
virus let's take a quick walk down
memory lane to see how diagnostic
testing for kova 19 has evolved thus far
and think a little bit about what we
might expect in the future
in the very beginning when the world was
still in shock and we had no idea what
we were dealing with we started with
symptomatic diagnoses like lung ct scans
and bronchiologe
these were very expensive to run at over
a thousand dollars a test and had to be
run and interpreted by experienced
clinicians and they were extremely
invasive
once we had a better idea of what we
were dealing with and understood a bit
more about the structure and genetic
makeup of sars cody2 we shifted to
active disease diagnoses
this started with molecular diagnostics
like pcr which looked for the genetic
material inside the virus and later
included antigen testing which uses
antibodies to detect proteins on the
surface of the virus
these tests were less invasive but still
not as fun as most were nasopharyngeal
swabs
testing could now be done at a central
lab and the cost per test dropped
between 75 dollars to 200
as testing demand grew more tests became
available to accommodate higher volume
testing and screening much of the same
technology was and is being used but in
a slightly different way
specimen types became less invasive with
mid-turbinate or anterior nerve swabs
and even saliva
central labs adopted to accommodate
adapted to accommodate higher volume
testing with higher throughput solutions
and pooling and point of care
testimonies including rapid energy tests
the cost per test again dropped between
10 and 20 dollars
and where we go from there i hope will
be more about community surveillance to
identify breakouts before they spread
i imagine this will involve more
widespread environmental monitoring and
things like air and wastewater which
would be the least evasive sample type
of all
next slide please
so let's look briefly at the viral
dynamics of a typical symptomatic
cova-19 viral infection the schematic on
the right shows the viral load in copies
per milliliter on the y-axis as a
function of time after symptom odd cell
on the x-axis
the general consensus from the
literature is that lies sars cov2
particles have a hard time replicating
in culture if the sample was collected
more than nine days after the symptoms
began
this is why the viral load quickly drops
in the graph
so the peak period of infectiousness and
therefore highest risk of transmission
is three days before to eight days after
symptoms began so this is what we're
looking for
there are three types of diagnostic
tests relevant to patient management and
pandemic control
one serology test can only provide
indirect evidence of infection only one
to two weeks after the onset of symptoms
because this is when it's possible to
detect the host antibodies generated in
response to the pathogen or vaccine
depicted in that part is depicted in
purple and blue lines on the right side
of the graph
serology tests are thus best used for
surveillance and to inform public policy
although they can't yet be used as proof
of immunity
only pcr and antigen tests can be used
for
to diagnose an acute infection pcr
pcr tests work by detecting the genetic
material or rna of the virus
rna is amplified exponentially when
short probe sequences bind to their
specific target and so very small
amounts of viral genetic material can be
detected
these are the most sensitive and
accurate cova 19's cova 19 tests on the
market quickly being adopted as the gold
standard in testing there are hundreds
of rtpcr tests on the market right now
and although there may be slight
differences in the detection limit that
depends on the sample type and the
instrumentation platform they're all
highly sensitive with lower limits of
detection in the tens to hundreds of
copies per milliliter range
another important feature of pcr tests
is the ability to amplify and detect
multiple sequences simultaneously this
is done by attaching different color
fluorophores to each amplified target
sequence this is what's meant by
multiplexing
where pcr tests work by amplifying and
detecting sequences that encode the
viral proteins antigen tests work by
detecting surface proteins or antigens
themselves
since there's no amplification step
antigen tests are not nearly as
sensitive as pcr in the schematic you
can see the detection limit for antigen
tests is that the hundreds of thousands
to millions of copies per milliliter
range which means they're less likely to
detect
less likely to detect an infection if
the amount of virus is low lower
sensitivity makes antigen tests more
relevant for diagnostic testing within
five to seven days of symptom onset when
viral loads are the highest rather than
for testing asymptomatic people or those
at the beginning or tailing edges
tilling end of the disease when the
viral loads are lower
so now that we understand a bit more
about testing in general i'd like to
provide an overview of thermo fisher
scientific's rapid response to covet 19.
so our mission really is to enable our
customers to make the world healthier
cleaner and safer
the scale and depth of our capabilities
has never been more vital
thermo fisher scientific has a long
history of responding rapidly in public
health crises we worked hard to make a
difference not just during the sars-ko
v2 outbreak but also during ebola zika
h1n1 and even anthrax
while we're talking about sars kovi 2
detection kits for diagnostic and
surveillance applications today thermo
fisher also has a hand in ppe to protect
researchers and front-line workers and
other scientific research tools like
those for genetic protein and cellular
analysis and in vaccine production and
clinical trial logistics
when the first case of cova-19 was
reported in wuhan in december 2019
researchers used our instruments to
perform cryo-electron microscopy
enabling the structure
of stars cov2 spike protein bound to the
h2 receptor to be published within only
two months
over 1200 boxes of reagents and assays
were fast-tracked so researchers could
quickly develop tests
our genetic analyzer instrument was even
used to read the sequence of the viral
genome setting the roadmap for
diagnostic tests
sequence in hand we worked rapidly to
develop a multiplex real-time pcr
diagnostic kit to enable clinical and
public health laboratories to quickly
diagnose covenant 19.
we strive to be the global leader in
covenanting testing solutions globally
over half of all cova 19 testing is
being performed using our technology
we've rapidly scared scaled our
production capacity enabling us to make
over 20 million kits per week and beyond
if necessary
laboratories have been constrained with
supplies of reagents consumables and
instruments
we promise a reliable secured supply
chain to reliably meet global testing
demands
we're vertically integrated as a single
supplier and distributor for consumables
reagents instruments and software and
provide 24 7 services and support for
laboratories running or looking to run
kova testing
later in the talk i'll share a success
story from the university of colorado
and how they were able to rely on our
high volume manufacturing capabilities
secured supply chain and focused service
and support to meet unprecedented
testing demands for the citizens of
colorado
the u.s food and drug administration
authorized the applied biosystems
tacpath cova 19 combo kit for emergency
use authorization just days after the
who declared coven 19 a global pandemic
this is a highly sensitive scalable and
vitro diagnostic solution that contains
both the assays and controls needed for
the real-time pcr detection of rna from
sardis cov2 the kit is authorized to be
used on some of the most used real-time
pcr instruments in the world and with a
variety of sample types
since then we've continued to grow and
enhance the tacpath testing portfolio
enabling an un uninterrupted product
supply to support our customers evolving
needs
knowing that cyrus cov2 is not the only
respiratory virus and that covet and flu
have overlapping overlapping symptoms
the following winter we released the
takpath colvin 19 flu a flu bee combo
kit this is a single test for stars cov2
influenza a and influenza b that can
detect and differentiate between
covalent and flu and in europe we also
release the taxpayer copper 19 slua b
rsv kit
we also offer high throughput testing
options with the high throughput combo
kit which is used in conjunction with
the automated amplitude solution and
also the pooling
five samples simultaneously in a single
reaction enabling more tests to be
processed faster with fewer materials
the most recent additions to our testing
menu use an innovative assay design with
eight targets across three genomic
regions
the rna's p combo kit includes human
sample conformation by targeting the
rna's t gene which serves as an
endogenous control to ensure sample
integrity quality and extraction
this kit detects active infections in
symptomatic patients as well as
asymptomatic individuals
the fast pcr combo kit is a
direct-to-pcr workflow from raw saliva
enabling widespread hype frequency
testing
and i'd like to draw attention to the
products indicated with the exclamation
point as these ones offer the s gene
advantage and i'll be discussing the
assay design in the next part of the
talk
next slide please
so now let's take a closer look at how
the assays are designed and built with
mutations in mind
the applied biosystems techpath cova19
diagnostic tests use a multi-target
design to compensate for emerging
variants of mutations
the three targeted protein regions open
reading frame 1ab the spike protein or s
and the nucleocapsid protein and were
strategically chosen with the goal to
have high specificities towards sars
cov2 thereby reducing the risk of
detecting any other coronaviruses that
might have similar sequences
our assay continues to remain targeted
specificity to 100 percent of currently
available complete genomes for sars cov2
in fact we continuously monitor the
literature and the databases to make
sure of this
by analyzing three different target
regions our assay design confers
built-in redundancy for mutations if one
of the probes fail the presence of the
other two still indicate presence of the
virus
in the schematic here you can see you
would get a positive result on the left
if two or more targets are amplified in
the top example all three regions are
amplified in the bottom that depicts
what would happen if you would still get
a positive result if only one of the
targets was not able to generate a
signal
since region one and three are still
positive then the overall result is
still positive for stars cov2
a sample is only negative if none of the
type if none of the viral targets are
detected and if only one is detected
that's considered inconclusive and the
result should be repeated
as part of our post-market surveillance
efforts we collect review and analyze
data on the performance of our tests
including assessing whether any emerging
mutations overlap with our assay design
currently there is only one mutation to
be aware of in relation to the tax pass
copa 19 portfolio and that's the
deletion at position 6970 within the s
gene which is most often associated with
but not limited to
uh variant b11529 and b117
since these assays are designed to
detect multiple genetic targets the
overall test sensitivity should not be
impacted by either variant
the s gene dropout pattern coupled with
the robust n and open reading frame 1a
signal was used as an early indicator of
the b117 or alpha string i included a
few literature references on the right
showing how monitoring this s gene
dropout pattern was useful during the
alpha outbreak
the same phenomenon has been observed
for omricon and is currently being used
as a preliminary test for the variant to
be followed up by sequencing based
confirmation should the s gene fail
detection
joanna will be discussing this more with
you later in her part of the
presentation
so now that you understand the strategy
behind our assay design let's look at
the workflow and scalability of our
tests
samples are first collected from
patients at a collection site there are
six authorized specimen types so far the
time to receive samples at the testing
lab may vary
to prepare the samples rna is extracted
from the viral particles using the
magmax viral pathogen ii nucleic acid
nucleic isolation kit
this can either be done manually or with
the automated kingfisher flex
purification system which takes about 25
minutes to run
the qpcr reactions are then set up using
the reagents and controls supplied with
the tacpath cova 19 combo kit and run on
a supported rt-pcr instrument
once the once the thermocycling is
complete the interpretive software
automatically interprets the genetic
analysis results performs qc checks
against all the controls and
automatically generates a report
covering each specimen
the end-to-end workflow can be completed
for 94 specimens in a 96 well play in
under 3 hours or 382 specimens in a 384
well play in under six and a half hours
next slide please so here's an example
of how you can scale your throughput by
using a single kingfisher flex two 7 500
fast pcr systems and two full-time
employees per shift over 24 hours by
staggering the workflow you could ramp
up to 2726
results per day
and for labs that need to process even
more samples and are looking for
something a bit more automated we offer
the amplitude solution highly automated
requiring only four full-time employees
amplitude amplitude can run a thousand
to eight thousand cobin 19 samples per
day
the amplitube solution is backed by
proven innovative technology because
it's compatible with the takpath coven
19 high throughput combo kit which uses
a multi-target assay design that i
described earlier to compensate for
emerging variants
as you may recall from the slide showing
our techpaths portfolio the high
throughput kit is one of our products
that can utilize the s gene
advantage pattern and may help identify
samples infected with the 6970 deletion
in the spike protein
as i stated in the beginning we promise
a secure consistent supply of reagents
and consumables even during times when
testing demands are record-breakingly
high
and with that i'm proud to show you an
example of how we were able to keep all
of our promises and enabled our
customers at the university of colorado
at their testing lab to meet
unprecedented testing demands as they
put it they went from a boutique
molecular diagnostics lab and into the
fire
the gray line is a measure of the
molecular diagnostics workload in the
year prior to the pandemic and you can
probably guess what the red line is by
the huge spike in workload in march of
2020 their workload tripled in three
months
before they adopted the amplitude
solution they were using tests and
instruments from a variety of sources
and were limited by the number of tests
that they could run each week due to
supply limitations and other allocation
constraints including expected shipments
being diverted to the dod
so without a secure supply chain they
were asked to perform over 2 000 tests
per day
that was their estimate for what their
throughput was going to be
with a little bit of logistical planning
for the for the lab and hiring a few new
employees uc health was more than happy
to have a designated testing area for
cova 19 samples given the current state
of the pandemic at the time
the promise of being able to run over 4
000 tests per day and having a secured
supply of over a million tests made the
amplitude solution the best option for
them
next slide please
so the reason i'm so proud to share this
story is because by enabling uc health
to meet these increases in testing
demand they were enabled to dramatically
increase test access to the citizens of
colorado
we were able to help them remedy their
previous problem with receiving
materials by providing palletized
shipments of twenty thousand or forty
thousand test kits
in fact we even provided an extra
inventory of fifty thousand kits so that
they could have them on hand if they
need a rose
the only unexpected problem was that
they had so many kits they didn't know
where to store them and so they had to
use the hallway
overstock was a much more preferable
issue than under stock and so the end
result is that they were able to exceed
their initial testing demand for 2 000
tests per day
on the histogram on the bottom right you
can see the number of rna tests used
every two weeks beginning in march
through june 2021
on the very first bar on the left from
march you can see that the total number
of tests dramatically rose from around
four thousand every two weeks to over
thirty thousand
just to remind you they were doing when
they were doing their planning and they
were trying to predict what the testing
demand might be they thought they'd be
doing only four thousand every two weeks
and so i'm happy that amplitude worked
out so well for them because the demand
was even higher than what they expected
peaking at over 30 000
so aside from being able to meet the
volume of test demands they were using
the high throughput kit that offers the
s gene advantage and so they were also
able to monitor the spread of the alpha
variant based on this unique result
pattern
they never encountered this fgn pattern
until early february and at that time
the uk was also monitoring the same
pattern and when they reported that the
6970 deletion was present in over 99 of
the sequence of the
the
of the sequence dropout samples and the
european cdc also recommended using
multi-target pcr assays to investigate
further
you see health then decided to send over
2 000 of their samples out for
sequencing and lo and behold
over 99 percent of them were indeed b117
the histogram on the right shows all of
the covid positive samples coming from
amplitude between february and june from
the alpha wave and categorizes each
result based on the s gene pattern you
can see the ones in orange that
exhibited the s gene pattern form a peak
that mirrors exactly what we now known
as the alpha wave
and with that i'd like to conclude part
one of the presentation
pcr testing demand is now higher than
ever with the current surge in omri-con
thermo-fissure scientific has been at
the forefront of the pandemic and is a
global leader in copenhagen testing
solutions
the tacpath multiplex assay design
targets three regions of sars cov2 to
compensate for emerging mutations and
variants
attack path workflow was adaptable to
high volume testing needs with the
amplitude solution
the s dropout pattern was
along with the amplitude solution were
useful for meeting high volume testing
needs at the university of colorado
and with that i'd like to pass it over
to jelena for the second part of the
talk
thank you so much vanessa so my name is
elena fenstra and today i would like to
talk about the emergence of different
styroscopes variants including omicron
why they are important what are their
clinical implications and what
surveillance solutions can be applied
for their detection discrimination and
identification in patient uh samples
so um since the detection of the
original strain of sarsakoptu in buhan
in december 2019 the global transmission
of the virus has led to significant
viral evolution and while all viruses
mutate rna viruses mutate at
high
rates like
stars cov2 and under selective pressures
the new variants are emerging and the
starscop2 virus was estimated to acquire
one to two mutations per month but
throughout the pandemic several sars
cop2variants immersed which contained
higher number of mutations than
scientists um anticipated and this
philogenetic tree here shows the
evolution of sarskovic ii from the
initial buhan strain identified in
december 2019 which is shown here in the
center and the circulating variants are
classified into lineages and these
concentric circles represent the time
throughout the pandemic and you can see
with each month that was passing by the
picture was getting more and more
complex with more variants
emerging in some periods during the
pandemic there were high numbers of
different variants circulating for
example if we look at 2020 we can see
several variants of concern that were
circulating at the same time such as
alpha beta and gamma to be later
replaced by the delta variant in 2020
and most recently by omicron um
at the end of 2021
shown here
in
red
so what are the implications of these
variants so first of all the mutations
that these variants carry might um offer
the virus in advantage for it to spread
more rapidly and you know through the
population with increased human to human
uh transmission second they may be
associated with higher viral loads and
affect the disease severity and leads to
worse clinical
outcomes and of course some mutation
might render the virus
more resistant to
treatment such as
antibody therapies or they can lead to
escape of vaccine immunity or immunity
acquired by a previous infection with a
different viral variant and of course
some of the mutations in the variants
may impact the performance of diagnostic
tests which are used to detect the
coronavirus and based on these key
characteristics and the risk that they
pose to public health the variants are
classified into these four categories uh
variance being monitored variance of
interest variance of concern and
variance of high consequence now so far
no variant has been designated this
variant of high consequence but there
have been several
variants of concern and let's look at
those in a bit more detail
so currently according to the usc dc
there are two variants which are
considered to be variants of concern and
these are
omicron and delta and there was a number
of other variants and there you see them
they are currently classified as
variants being monitored in this great
box and some of them marked in red such
as alpha beta gamma and epsilon were
actually previously having the status of
variance of concern during 2020 and 2021
and if you look at the two graphs on
your right you can see the timeline of
the
pandemic
and you can see that there were several
variants that were very dominant
throughout this period so for example
first such variant was alpha which
emerged in the uk in autumn of 2020 and
you can see there was a period of time
when this variant was accounting for the
majority of covet 19 cases
in the u.s marked here on the lower
right graph in red however then the
delta variant emerged in summer of 2021
and you can see that in green that is
the very sort of overtime overtook all
the other variants that were circulating
and became the dominant variant in the
us but also worldwide and then um
as the alpha beta gamma and other
variants were not circulating uh and not
accounting for a high proportion of
cases in september 2021 they have not
been considered anymore as variants of
concern and have been given this variant
being monitored status and then you see
in november 2021 the omicron variant
emerged and really in record time as
shown in this graph in purple it took
over um the delta variant and became the
dominant variant in the u.s and again
this graph represents the the united
states situation but very similar
picture
could be seen for many other countries
worldwide
now if we look a little bit more closely
at the mutation profiles of some of
these main variants of concern it's
important to understand
that the stars cover two virus has the
so-called spike or s protein on its
surface which binds to the ac2 receptor
on the cells of the respiratory tract
and enables the virus to enter the cells
and infect them and as it is on the
surface of the virus the s protein is
also the target of most of the vaccines
that have been developed for sarcophagi
now mutations in starch of two variants
of concern affect the s gene and in this
figure you can see in purple all
mutations in the s gene in the delta
omicron and alpha variance of concern
and what is immediately visible is that
there is a significantly higher number
of mutations in the omicron
variant compared to for example alpha or
or delta and there were a 30 in total
and this high number of mutations was
one of the main concerns when omicron
was first affected as it was expected
that if a protein undergoes so many
mutations it might more efficiently
evade the immune response induced by
vaccine or previous infections and what
you can also appreciate from this figure
is that there are certain mutations
which these variants of concern have in
common and we've marked them here with
with these red
arrows
and uh i just want to point out one of
them which is for example the deletion
6970 which is a important condition that
was found in alpha and later on in
omicron variant but was not present in
the delta
variant of concern and some of these
mutations are referred to as mutations
of concern also because later on a
functional studies demonstrated that
they have
an impact on the viral properties
so um in the next couple of slides i
would like to focus a little bit more
on the omicron variant so the omicron
variant was first detected in november
2021 in south africa and by january of
2022 it was present in almost every
country worldwide and the emergence of
this variant was responsible for the
latest wave of sarcopte infections and
the incidence was really above
everything else that was earlier
reported during the pandemic so you can
see on this upper graph the situation in
different uh doubletoe regions and you
can see that the peak of the infections
was much higher than previously seen
during the pandemic but what was also
observed if you look at the graph
below showing situation in the uk that
the peak was also very sharp so the
number of infection rose significantly
and then also dropped rather uh quickly
and you know if we look at the features
of this omicron variance now the first
thing that was very clear is that it has
a growth advantage over the delta
variant that there was an increased risk
of infection and that in addition it did
have immune escape properties in terms
of increased risk of a reinfection and
potential to escape vaccine-induced
immunity and interestingly the omicron
variant was found to localize more in
the upper
respiratory tract with potentially
reduced ability to infect the lung and
thus also that led to reduced risk of
hospitalization in infected individuals
now of course with this high number of
mutations that we've seen that the
s-protein of the omicron variant has
there was a potential effect on some of
the monoclonal antibodies that were
applied in treatment of patients with
corpus 19 while for example diagnostic
tests were mostly um not affected um by
this variant and you know as vanessa
already explained
and the three target design of the
starscope 2 essay and the fact that the
s gene target does not amplify if this
deletion 6970 is present in the virus
can really offer an advantage in terms
that the same essay that is used for the
detection of the virus can provide an
indication for the presence of variants
that carry this deletion 6970 and one of
these variants is omicron and in fact
the group of tulio de oliveira who
actually first reported on the omicron
variant later on published an article in
science where they explained how this as
gene target
or failure or estrogen dropout how we
refer to it can be used to track the
spread of the omicron variant usfda and
also other agencies stated that the
pattern of this estrogen dropout may be
a signal for the omicron variant while
the sensitivity of the test is not
impacted but of course the variant would
need to be confirmed by additional
methods such as sequencing or or
genotyping
and in fact for example the united
kingdom public health agencies have used
the asgen target failure to track the
spread of variants carrying this
deletion 6970
throughout the pandemic
actually at the national level and these
are some graphs that were published by
the uk government
and i just want to show you for example
in the upper graph
how um
actually at the end of 2020 the
laboratories noticed that there were
some samples starting to show up with
the estrogen dropout they are shown here
in
purple and that was actually the time
when the alpha variant
emerged and this is how they detected it
and they tracked its spread
and later on um sometime you see here
around
may uh 2021 they suddenly saw that there
are samples that are showing
obliquification of the sg so there was
no more estrogen dropout this is the
green curve and this is actually the
time when the delta variants emerged and
how they could use now the amplification
of the s gene to track the
delta variant spread in the uk and
similarly they've used this exact same
uh feature of the jackpot as they also
when the omicron variant uh emerged at
the end of 2021 you see again the purple
cur and how they could detect samples
with the obtuse dropout and clearly you
know should the next variant replacing
omnicron not carry this deletion 6970
this feature of detect that essay could
again be useful in this sort of terms of
of surveillance
um let me yeah
so um of course um i would also like to
mention some of the sub lineages of
omicron
and in this graph you can see them
listed so um there are several sub
lineages they are referred to as ba 0.1
ba 1.1 b 8.2 and b 8.3
and you can see in this upper image some
differences in mutation profiles between
these different uh lineages
and for example uh the ba 0.2 variant
was first reported actually in denmark
because this is one of the countries
that was first to drop all of these
public health measures against the
coronavirus
and you can see on this slide or on your
lower right
on the image that um the ba2 variant
very quickly became the dominant variant
actually in in denmark at the beginning
of 2022 and this picture was not only
observed in denmark it's the same for
example in south africa india and quite
a few other countries what we know about
this v8.2 sublinear is that it has an
increased growth rate compared to ba 0.1
omicron which was the main circulating
link previously and a study published by
danish researchers where there were the
most cases um already showed that there
is a higher secondary attack rate among
contacts it's important to point out
that this particular sub lineage does
not carry deletion 6970 so um
it is actually sg in target uh positive
and now in the next part of my talk i
would like to present uh some of the
surveillance solutions for detection and
discrimination of starscope 2 variants
now of course the gold standard for
starscope to detection is rtpcr on rma
isolated from nasopharyngeal swap
samples or other sample types and once
we know that the virus is present in a
sample there are methods for variant and
mutation identification and that can be
done either for example with sanger
sequencing to confirm specific mutations
or with rtpcr genotyping assays that can
provide a very rapid option to detect a
certain mutation of concern and the
advantage of using the target set
mutation panel of course is that the
results can be obtained more quickly and
on the same instrument which is used to
detect the presence of the virus now of
course we also have the let's say what
is considered more classic surveillance
methodologies which would be the
sequencing solution which can be
performed either on certain parts of the
genome such as the s gene which we know
undergoes a lot of mutations or next
generation sequencing could be used to
sequence the entire viral genome and
potentially identify a novel variants
and i would like to go now in a little
bit more detail about each of these
specific technologies and how one could
implement their them in their specific
settings so for example the techman um
fires cove2 mutation panel offers a menu
of more than 60 verified real-time pcr
genotyping assays and we know that you
know some of the mutations in these
variants are shared between the variants
and some are very specific for a
particular variant of concern so
laboratories are very flexible and they
can decide on their own what kind of
panel they want to build for variant
detection the advantages are their
results can be obtained very quickly and
using the same instrumentation as for
detection of the presence of the virus
and this approach also offers some
flexibility in terms when the new
variants emerge or when some variants
stop circulating then these parts of the
panel can be of course
edited and now how to discriminate the
variant using a mutation panel so here
depicted on your right is an allelic
discrimination plot which is just an
example to show if you run one a
genotyping essay what would the results
look like and you could see here that
for example each dot represents one
sample and for example the red dots
would represent samples in which the
essay detects the mutation and the blue
cluster dots would be the samples that
would be wild type for this
particular position that we are looking
at and here i've just listed some of the
assets we have available
for the omicron or for the
delta
variant and of course the labs can
choose how many assets they would like
to run to be able to discriminate
between
omicron and
delta
positive
samples and if you want to know more
about how mutation panel was used to
track the omnichrome variant spread in
the us there is this publication which
resulted from a collaborative effect
between the nih helix rosalind thermo
fisher scientific and
other partners and within this study of
four essay panel was evaluated for
detection and differentiation of delta
and omicron variants of concern you can
see in this table here the results of
the study demonstrated the performance
of the genotyping
approach for detection of these variants
when compared to a whole genome
sequencing and in this particular panel
they have chosen one essay specific for
the delta variant and 3s is specific for
the omicron variant and the results show
that the genocide approach had a very
good agreement of 100 percent uh ppa and
99
mpas compared to whole genome sequencing
and the real-time tracker um to
support the rapid genotyping program for
stars com2 in the united states was
developed by rosalind it can be accessed
at the link provided below and here on
this slide you can just see the
screenshot of the information that this
tracker is depicting and the currently
circulating sars co2 variants across the
us the additional significance of this
tracker is that if we start seeing a
trend where these undetermined cases
that don't fall into alpha or or the
downfalls are into delta or omicron
start to increase it means we are
looking at the potentially new variance
showing up that we would then need to uh
sequence um and identify uh further um
and of course sequencing is a method of
choice for identification of new
variants the next generation sequencing
can be used for surveillance of the full
viral genome and the ion amplistic stars
cover to insight research essay covers
99.7 of the viral genome and all
potential stereotypes and it enables
complete sequencing of the starscopter
genome even in the low viral load
samples by offering excellent
performance as the virus mutates um this
essay can be used on the ion shaft and
ion gene studio s5 series systems but
also on the fully
automated
ion torrent genexis integrated sequencer
which offers a one day turnaround time
now of course individual amplifiers can
be confirmed using sanger sequencing
which we know is the gold standard for
sequencing short stretches of the viral
genome and detection of mutations it is
cost effective and the protocols and
primer sequencing sets are available for
surveillance either of the full length
of the
s gene which undergoes highest number of
mutations or for confirmation of sars
co2 variants and of course labs can
select low to high throughput options
for a sample to result workflow
in one day
and in my last slide i would just like
to summarize by saying that starscope 2
continues to evolve and will likely
become
endemic with new variants emerging in
the future uh we know that testing
continues to play a critical role
in patient management also in containing
the spread in tracking current variants
and early identification of new variants
um thermo fisher scientific offers a
comprehensive menu of testing solutions
for sars coffee too including the ultra
high throughput options to deal with the
searches as we recently witnessed with
omicron as well as for uh surveillance
of um emerging variants so um for more
information please do visit
www.turbofisher.comcobit19
and i believe it is now time for
questions
okay thank you vanessa and elena for
that wonderful presentation
we're going to start now the live q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question that you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far right of
your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's go ahead and get started
it looks like we have
two questions coming in for vinnet for
vanessa
so given the differences in sensitivity
between antigen and pcr tests
when does it make sense to use either
technology
and as a follow-up
you've talked a lot about lab-based pcr
tests and high-volume testing does
thermo-fissure offer any point of care
test solutions so vanessa
yeah thank you
so in general antigen tests are less
sensitive but they're a lot quicker to
run and cheaper to run this is why the
cdc recommends following up any negative
antigen test with a pcr
for confirmation especially for
symptomatic
antigen tests are
cheaper and offer the promise of a rapid
turnaround time often within minutes and
so they're suitable to use when
prevalence is really high and you need
to quickly identify symptomatic
individuals for the most likely at risk
of transmitting the virus to others
so due to their much higher sensitivity
pcr tests are ideal in any situation
where you need to have very high
confidence that your first result is
accurate
there's actually two main classes of pcr
tests so there's the lab-based pcr that
we discussed mostly in the talk
and those use well-established lab
processes that are run by trained
technicians and although it only takes a
couple hours to run the actual test you
also have to take into account
consideration the time that it takes to
transport the samples to and from the
lab making the turnaround time a little
bit longer but still usually within a
day
lab-based pcr tests are the easiest to
scale up and they're ideal for
high-volume processing supporting local
and national level testing efforts such
as in schools or in corporations
and rapid pcr so these are more point of
care so this uses newer technology
and that allows it to be performed at
the site of sample collection
rapid pcr tests are ideal for evaluating
high-risk congregate settings such as
emergency rooms clinics hospitals and
nursing homes
and we do offer the acula sars cove 2
test and the features of that include
getting results within just 30 minutes
it's a streamlined process with a clio
waived workflow it has a simplified
sample collection supporting nasal swabs
and nasal mid turbinate swabs
and another benefit is that it can be
stored at room temperature so you don't
need
refrigeration um
and since it is based on pcr the results
are highly accurate the percent positive
agreement was 95.8 percent to 100 and
negative percent agreement was 100 in
both prospective and retrospective
clinical studies and it's also highly
sensitive with the lod
less than 500
rna naat detectable units per milliliter
using a reference panel
so
yeah good question thank you all right
okay great thanks so much vanessa um so
this next question i think is for elena
um how many assays are needed in order
to detect a variant of concern using the
genotyping approach
yeah so
you know as i said during my talk um
every variant will carry mutations which
are you know specific for that
particular variant and as well as those
mutations that might also be present in
other variants so it's very important
that at least one essay that a lab
selects to run is specific for that
variant but how many in total the lab
chooses to do is really depends on the
lab and the current situation uh in the
region they are in and as i demonstrated
during my talk for example one approach
to differentiate between delta and
omicron was to pick uh four essays but
for example some other labs might
want to use at least two essays per
variant or at least three assets per
variant and so on and of course it also
depends on how many variants are
circulating at the same time so for
example uh in 2020 when we had the
so all of these at the same time then of
course the labs were picking a little
bit um uh bigger uh panels and you know
again i would like to stress that this
flexibility that the laboratory has to
you know remove essays from the panel
and add new assets as new variants start
to emerge is also um very very important
and we found that you know the labs have
found is very useful in their uh
practice
great okay thank you so much
um i think we're gonna i think we've got
time for one more
question um so let's see here so now
that the omicron variant is the main
circulating variant
can s gene target failure still be
useful in the context of surveillance so
elena this looks like a question for you
again
yeah sure so uh
the answer is absolutely you know and
and in fact we already see that it is
very useful because um as i've shown you
uh you know in some countries like
denmark and and so on there has been the
spread of the ba2 omni from sub lineage
that's still in the u.s um accounts for
a small proportion of the cases but for
example this variant doesn't carry the
deletion
6970 which means it would have the
esteem amplified and the labs would very
easily be able to track the ba2 variant
spread because they could see the
difference between positive samples with
the estrogen dropout and those um
without the estrogen dropout so you know
we we have seen the value of of this uh
feature of the attackpad essay really
been used by many labs
worldwide and of course you know the
exact variant would need to be then
confirmed by additional testing but at
least the lab would know how to focus
these efforts really on the samples that
you know um that we already know what
you could expect um which variant is
in it
okay great great thank you so much
um all right so thank you again elena
and vanessa for your time today in
discussing thermo fisher's omicron
response and solutions for detection and
surveillance
we would also like to thank lab roots
our sponsor and thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before you go i'd like to thank you the
audience for joining us today and for
your interesting questions
we apologize that we didn't get to all
of them today
um the webcast can be viewed on demand
so labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event and so until the next time
have a good day and goodbye thank you
for joining us thank you so much
you